This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. In 1976, the Austrian Formula One Racer, Nikki Lauda, was involved in a fiery crash at the German Grand Prix. Taking a 150 mile per hour turn, he swirled off the track and hit a fence. His racing car exploded into flames. Another car crashed into his vehicle. The associated press reported what happened next. The race was restarted, but for louder it was a race for life. While his fellow drivers jokked for position, he was being rushed to an intensive care unit
这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是香卡·维丹塔。1976年，奥地利一级方程式赛车手尼基·劳达在德国大奖赛中遭遇了一场烈焰腾腾的车祸。在以每小时150英里的速度过弯时，他的赛车冲出赛道并撞上了护栏。他的赛车瞬间爆炸起火。另一辆车撞上了他的座驾。美联社报道了接下来发生的事情。比赛重新开始，但对劳达来说，这是一场生死之战。当他的同行车手们在争夺位置时，他正被紧急送往重症监护室
with severe burns, fractures and lung damage. Surgeons pronounced he was near to death and last rights were administered. But Nikki Lauder refused to give up. He not only came back from near death, but in the weeks that followed, he staged one of the most astonishing recoveries in sports history. Just 40 days after doctors had given up hope and a priest had knelt at his bedside, the Austrian ace climbed back into the cockpit of his glaring red Ferrari. Nikolauda returned to the track, barely a month after he was presumed dead. His medical recovery had more to do with his iron will
身受重伤、骨折且肺部受损。外科医生宣布他濒临死亡，并进行了临终祈祷。但尼基·劳达拒绝放弃。他不仅从生死边缘挺了过来，而且在随后的几周里，上演了体育史上最令人震惊的复出之一。就在医生放弃希望、牧师跪在他床边的仅仅40天后，这位奥地利王牌车手再次坐进了那辆耀眼的红色法拉利座舱。尼基·劳达重返赛场，此时距离他被认为已经死亡仅仅过去了一个多月。他身体的康复，更多归功于他钢铁般的意志
than with master surgery. In an interview, Nikki Lauda made clear that quitting was not something he ever considered. First week after the accident, I couldn't take any decisions at all because it was too bad. After when it was feeling good, I wanted to race again.
而不是高超的外科手术。在一次采访中，尼基·劳达明确表示，放弃是他从未考虑过的事情。事故发生后的第一周，我根本无法做任何决定，因为情况太糟糕了。后来感觉好些了，我又想去比赛了。
RUN The annals of sports and business and science are filled with stories like this. Hearing them can give us the courage to confront challenges in our own lives. But do they always give us the right message? Today we kick off a month-long series where we'll examine the psychological factors that shape whether we achieve our goals. We're calling it success to point out. We begin with an overlooked component of success. The fine line between staying the course between staying the course and stubbornness, this week on Hidden Brain. What makes a person successful? Many people would say it's the capacity to start a promising venture and see it through
运行体育、商业和科学的史册里充满了这样的故事。听到这些故事能给我们勇气去面对自己生活中的挑战。但它们总是给我们传递正确的信息吗？今天，我们开启一个为期一个月的系列节目，探讨塑造我们能否实现目标的心理因素。我们将其命名为“直奔成功”。我们从一个被忽视的成功要素开始。坚持到底与固执之间的微妙界限，本周的《Hidden Brain》。是什么造就了一个成功的人？许多人会说，是有能力开启一个充满前景的项目并将其坚持到底
to completion. At the University of Chicago, economists John List agrees that grit and determination are vitally important. But in his life and his research, he's found there's a secret ingredient to success that is often not given the Hollywood treatment. John List, welcome to Hidden Brain. Hey, thanks so much for having me, Shankar. John, in the early 2000s, you took a leave from your academic position to become a senior economist in the White House. You were advising the administration of President George W. Bush.
直至完成。在芝加哥大学，经济学家约翰·利斯特认同坚毅和决心至关重要。但在他的生活和研究中，他发现成功有一个秘密成分，而这个成分往往没有被好莱坞化。约翰·利斯特，欢迎来到《隐藏的大脑》。嘿，非常感谢邀请我来，香卡。约翰，在2000年代初，你请假离开学术岗位，去白宫担任高级经济学家。你当时在为乔治·W·布什总统的政府提供咨询。
While you were there, you worked on a piece of legislation that was very important to you. What was this legislation? The legislation was called the Clear Skies Act or the Clear Skies Initiative. And the idea was to create a cap and trade scheme that would try to combat socks, nox and mercury from power plants. Sox refers to sulfur dioxide, nox refers to nitrogen oxide, both are harmful to our lungs. And the cap and trade scheme was kind of neat because it was an auction system
在职期间，你参与了一项对你非常重要的立法。这项立法是什么？这项立法被称为《清凉空气法案》或《清凉空气倡议》。其理念是创建一个总量管制与交易机制，试图解决发电厂排放的二氧化硫、氮氧化物和汞问题。二氧化硫指的是二氧化硫，氮氧化物指的是一氧化氮，两者都对我们的肺部有害。这种总量管制与交易机制非常巧妙，因为它是一个拍卖系统
along with a cap that attempted to really lower these emissions. I think in the end, it was to clean up local air pollution problems, but also to take a bite out of climate change and long-term issues too. My clear skies legislation will cut power plant pollution and improve the health of our citizens. Four years of debate is enough. I urge Congress to pass legislation that makes America more secure and less dependent on foreign energy.
配合总量限制，旨在真正减少这些排放。我认为最终目的是为了清理当地的空气污染问题，同时也为应对气候变化和长期问题出自己的一份力。我的《清凉空气法案》将减少发电厂污染，改善我们公民的健康。四年的辩论已经够了。我敦促国会通过这项使美国更加安全、减少对外国能源依赖的立法。
So you walked into this legislation, what happened to it? Did it go to Congress for a vote? Yes, I worked pretty hard on it. That was one of the first issues I worked on. And we worked a fair amount with Senator James Inhoff, who was a chairman of the Committee on Environment and Public Works, worked a lot with Hillary Clinton, who was a very important the committee on Environment and Public Works worked a lot with Hillary Clinton, who was a very important member of the Environment and Public Works.
所以你介入了这项立法，它后来怎么样了？它送到国会投票了吗？是的，我为之付出了相当大的努力。这是我着手处理的第一批议题之一。我们与参议院环境与公共工程委员会主席詹姆斯·因霍夫参议员进行了相当多的合作，也与作为环境与公共工程委员会非常重要的成员希拉里·克林顿进行了大量合作，与环境与公共工程委员会非常重要的成员希拉里·克林顿进行了大量合作。
And we worked for about a year with them and the clear skies first Senate hearing was actually on April 8, 2003. And lo and behold, I was sitting on pins and needles waiting for the news to come back. And I received word back from the folks in Senator Clinton's camp and Senator Inhoff's camp. Then they told me both Republicans and Democrats
我们与他们合作了大约一年，《清凉空气法案》的第一次参议院听证会实际上是在2003年4月8日举行的。你看，我当时坐立难安，焦急地等待着消息传回。我收到了来自克林顿参议员阵营和因霍夫参议员阵营的人传来的消息。然后他们告诉我，无论是共和党人还是民主党人
voted no against the clear skies initiative. So like unanimously they voted no. That clear skies initiative. Like unanimously they voted no? That's what I understood. This was behind closed doors, but they told me that both Democrats and Republicans hated my initiative. Why was that, John?
都投票反对《清凉空气倡议》。也就是说他们一致投票反对。那个《清凉空气倡议》。就像他们一致投票反对一样？这就是我了解到的情况。这是在闭门会议上进行的，但他们告诉我，民主党和共和党都讨厌我的倡议。为什么会这样，约翰？
So what they had said was the Democrats wanted something more progressive. They wanted carbon in the clear skies initiative and the Republicans wanted something a little bit less ambitious in terms of having mercury in the bill. So this was sort of a bill written by me in line with what the White House wanted, but it was really a bill that had no supporters when it came to that subcommittee. Wow. So the Democrats wanted to have carbon in the bill and wouldn't support it if it didn't. The Republicans wanted to scale down the provisions involving mercury and they wouldn't support
所以他们的说法是，民主党想要更激进的方案。他们希望在《清凉空气倡议》中加入碳排放限制，而共和党则希望在法案中关于汞的规定上不那么雄心勃勃。所以这基本上是我根据白宫的要求起草的一份法案，但当它提交到那个小组委员会时，实际上是一份没有任何支持者的法案。哇。所以民主党希望法案中包含碳限制，如果没有就不支持。共和党希望缩减涉及汞的条款，除非满足条件，否则他们也不会支持
it unless it did. Between the two of those things, the bill basically didn't go anywhere. How did you feel when the news came down, John? Well, gosh, this is roughly 9, 10, 11 months on this bill. And I thought that we had the economic issues taken care of. I thought we had the political issues taken care of. So when that news came down, I mean, I was devastated. Did you try and fight to get it back on the calendar to keep it alive? Oh, absolutely. You don't write something like this and just give up so quickly.
在两者的拉锯下，这个法案基本上无疾而终了。当消息传来时，约翰，你有什么感觉？天哪，这大约是花了9、10、11个月才弄出来的法案。而且我认为经济问题我们已经处理妥当了。我认为政治问题我们也已经解决了。所以当消息传来时，我的意思是，我崩溃了。你有没有尝试过去争取让它重新回到日程表上，让它继续活着？哦，当然。你不会写出这样一份东西然后就这么轻易放弃的。
So of course, I fought and fought to get them to reconsider because I was thinking, look, I've spent all of this time and I don't want all of that time to be wasted. So I went back to them again and again in meetings and I still thought that there was a glimmer of hope, but in the end it just didn't come to fruition. It was not until John left government that he realized he had made a crucial mistake. There were things he could have accomplished, but he was so focused on the Clear Sky's initiative that he didn't have time to get to goals that were actually within reach. Some time later, John came by another striking example. This time, an entire company was doing
所以当然，我一次又一次地争取让他们重新考虑，因为我在想，听着，我花了这么多时间，我不想让所有这些时间都白白浪费。所以我一次又一次地在会议上找他们，我依然觉得还有一丝希望，但最终它还是没有实现。直到约翰离开政府后，他才意识到自己犯了一个致命的错误。本有一些事情他是可以完成的，但他太专注于《清凉空气倡议》，以至于没有时间去实现那些实际上触手可及的目标。一段时间后，约翰遇到了另一个鲜明的例子。这一次，一家公司正在做着
something very similar to what he had done in government. John was working at the time as the chief economist of the right-sharing company, Lyft. The company was actively working on a new initiative to increase customer loyalty. Makes perfect sense, right? Once you attract the customer, it's important to retain that customer. So one thing that a lot of firms do
与他在政府中所做的事情非常类似的事情。约翰当时正在网约车公司Lyft担任首席经济学家。该公司当时正在积极推进一项旨在提高客户忠诚度的全新计划。这完全说得通，对吧？一旦你吸引了客户，留住客户就至关重要。因此，许多公司常做的一件事
is they develop things like membership programs. So Lyft was considering introducing a membership program that we called LiftPink. And that membership program was something along the lines of, you pay an upfront fee, and then you receive perks such as discounted rides as you take more trips on lift. And did you think that this was going to work? I actually did. For a few reasons, but most importantly, we did a number of experiments, exploring different upfront fees, like $9.99, $10.99, $19.99, these monthly fees, and then looking at different things like discount rates,
就是开发诸如会员计划之类的内容。因此，Lyft当时正在考虑引入一项我们称之为Lyft Pink的会员计划。该会员计划大致是这样的：你预先支付一笔费用，然后就能获得各种优惠，比如随着你在Lyft上乘车次数的增加，可以享受乘车折扣。你当时觉得这会成功吗？我实际上觉得会的。原因有几个，但最重要的是，我们做了大量的实验，探讨了不同的预付费，比如9.99美元、10.99美元、19.99美元这些月费，然后观察诸如折扣率等不同的因素，
10% off, 20% off, et cetera. And what we kept finding is that people just continue to consume the number of lift rides at the same rate that they did before the membership program. So you had these reservations and you must have shared these reservations with your colleagues. Did they listen to you? Oh, absolutely.
比如九折、八折等等。然而我们不断发现的是，人们继续以与加入会员计划之前完全相同的频率来消费Lyft的乘车服务。所以你当时有这些保留意见，你一定和同事们分享过这些保留意见吧？他们听取你的意见了吗？哦，当然。
I shared them. And what I shared with them is that we have to be really careful when we roll this out. So they took account of our research and our data. But they still decided to roll out pink in a slightly different way. They rolled it out in the end of December of 2019. And they did tweak some things based on our data. As John's experiments had predicted, the loyalty program didn't really catch on. But by this time, a lot of people at the company had spent a lot of time working on lift pink. Now, I left, left in the spring of 2022,
我分享了。我向他们传达的是，我们在推出这个项目时必须非常小心。因此，他们确实考虑了我们的研究和数据。但他们最终还是决定以一种略有不同的方式推出Pink。他们在2019年12月底推出了它。并且他们根据我们的数据对一些东西进行了微调。正如约翰的实验所预测的那样，这个忠诚度计划并没有真正流行起来。但到了这个时候，公司里有很多人已经在Lyft Pink上花费了大量的时间。现在，我在2022年春天离开了Lyft，
but by the time I left, it was still sputtering along. And what has recently happened in October of 2022, lift actually reintroduced lift pink. And I think in part it was because the original membership program just wasn't working that well for them. reintroduced lift pink. And I think in part it was because the original membership program just wasn't working that well for them. In some ways they were doing what you did when you were in the White House, which is they had an idea, they love the idea,
但在我离开时，它依然在勉强维持。最近在2022年10月发生的事情是，Lyft实际上重新推出了Lyft Pink。我想部分原因是因为最初的会员计划对他们来说确实不太奏效。重新推出了Lyft Pink。我想部分原因是因为最初的会员计划对他们来说确实不太奏效。在某些方面，他们做的事情和你在白宫时做的一样，那就是他们有一个想法，他们热爱这个想法，
and they wanted to stick at it. I think that parallel is spot on. So they had an idea that really didn't look great right away. So what they did is they went and they tinkered with it a little bit. And when you look at the new lift pink, by and large, it's kind of the same structured program. John says this impulse to stick with it is something he's seen in both his professional and in his personal life. In 2015, he and his wife found they had hit a rough patch in their marriage. Yeah, that's kind of a tough one.
并且他们想要坚持下去。我认为这种平行关系非常贴切。所以他们有一个一开始看起来并不怎么好的想法。于是他们所做的就是去对它进行了一点修修补补。当你审视全新的Lyft Pink时，大体上它还是那种结构相同的程序。约翰说，这种坚持下去的冲动是他无论在职业生涯还是个人生活中都见过的情况。2015年，他和妻子发现他们的婚姻陷入了困境。是的，这有点艰难。
Now I've never talked about this publicly, but let's give it a try, since maybe it can help others work their way through a difficult moment in their own relationship. John and his wife had been high school sweethearts, but after many years together, they hit a crisis in their marriage. The idea of divorce was suddenly on the table. And I started to think, well, look, I have five kids and those kids back then were aged 9 to 16. I've invested a lot in this relationship and this family. And I don't want to waste that. This is my high school sweetheart.
现在我从未公开谈论过这个，但让我们试一试，因为也许它能帮助其他人度过他们自己感情中的困难时刻。约翰和他的妻子曾是青梅竹马的高中恋人，但在相伴多年后，他们的婚姻迎来了危机。离婚的想法突然摆上了台面。我开始想，好吧，我有五个孩子，当时那些孩子的年龄在9到16岁之间。我在这段关系和这个家庭上投入了大量心血。我不想浪费这些。这是我的高中恋人。
Somebody who I started dating when she was 15 and I was 16. So I decided to give it a go. Eventually, John and his wife decided to part ways. It was a painful decision, but in the end, the right one. Importantly, everyone got around that corner and everyone is healthy and happy. Their mental health, their physical health is in place. My ex-wife has a wonderful
一个我从她15岁、我16岁时就开始交往的人。所以我决定试一试。最终，约翰和他的妻子决定分道扬镳。这是一个痛苦的决定，但最终是一个正确的决定。重要的是，每个人都度过了那个难关，每个人都健康快乐。他们的心理健康、身体健康都维持得很好。我的前妻有一个美好的
partner. I have a wonderful partner. This is a win-win-win all around. Many guidebooks tell us how to stop things, how to create things, and how to complete things. It's far less common to hear advice on when to quit things. Why is that? That's when we come back. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedanta. This is Hidden Brain.
伴侣。我有一个美好的伴侣。这是一个皆大欢喜的圆满结局。许多指南告诉我们如何停止事情、如何创造事情以及如何完成事情。听到关于什么时候该放弃事情的建议则要少得多。这是为什么呢？广告回来后我们再聊。你正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》。我是香卡·维丹塔。这里是《隐藏的大脑》。
I'm Shankar Vedanta. Economist John List studies how people make choices. At the University of Chicago, he explores how we allow time, energy and resources to various demands in our lives. He's found that in many domains, personal, professional, political, many of us have a problem with quitting. Once we sink our teeth into something, we become the proverbial dog with a bone. We won't let go. We can't let go. Based in part on his own experiences with stubbornness, John is spend time trying to understand the psychological and cultural forces that keep us from quitting things we ought to let go
我是香卡·维丹塔。经济学家约翰·利斯特研究人们如何做出选择。在芝加哥大学，他探讨了我们如何将时间、精力和资源分配给我们生活中的各种需求。他发现在许多领域——个人、职业、政治领域，我们很多人在“放弃”这件事上都有问题。一旦我们对某事咬定不放，我们就会像那句老话里咬着骨头的狗一样。我们就是不肯放手。我们无法放手。部分基于他自己应对固执的经历，约翰花时间去理解那些阻止我们放弃本该放手之事的心理和文化力量。
John I understand that you grew up in a small town in Wisconsin. Tell me about your family and upbringing So I was raised in a small village called Sun Prairie, Wisconsin just outside of Madison, Wisconsin My grandfather was a truck driver My dad was a truck driver. My dad was a truck driver. My brother is a truck driver. My mother is a secretary. And I think it's fair to describe our family and our upbringing is one that was very warm and very loving. But one that was also disciplined. And essentially the proverbial blue collar family. I want to play you a clip from a man who has worshipped around Wisconsin and also lots of other places in the United
约翰，我听说你在威斯康星州的一个小镇长大。跟我讲讲你的家庭和成长经历吧。我是威斯康星州一个叫太阳草原（Sun Prairie）的小村庄长大的，就在威斯康星州麦迪逊市郊外。我外公是一名卡车司机。我爸爸是一名卡车司机。我爸爸是一名卡车司机。我哥哥是一名卡车司机。我妈妈是一名秘书。我认为用非常温馨、充满爱意来形容我们的家庭和成长经历是很恰当的。但同时也是一个很有纪律的家庭。本质上就是典型的蓝领家庭。我想放一段音频，来自一个在威斯康星州以及美国许多其他地方都被顶礼膜拜的人。我接触过赢家。我一生都在和高绩效的人打交道。各行各业的人。军方的人、政府的人、世界级的运动员、伟大的教练、私营部门的人，就像你们中的许多人一样。他们在做什么？我的意图是为你们每个人拿出一面镜子。一面你可以用来审视自己的镜子，去审视你的目标的广度和深度，以及你在追求这些目标时所付出的承诺、纪律和毅力。
States. I've been around winners. I've been around high performance people all my life. People all walks of life. People in military, people in government, world class athletes, great coaches, people in a private sector such as a lot of you. What do they do? It's my intention to see me and hold up for you a mirror. A mirror that you can look into and examine for yourself, the breadth and the depth of your goals and the commitment and the discipline and the perseverance you bring to the pursuit of those goals.
约翰，跟我讲讲你们家庭对绿湾包装工队著名橄榄教练文斯·隆巴迪（Vince Lombardi）的狂热喜爱。没错。所以当你看超级碗时，最后他们会颁发一个奖杯。这个奖杯被称为隆巴迪奖杯，以文斯·隆巴迪命名。在威斯康星州，他简直就像神一样。他曾是那支橄榄球队的教练。他说过诸如“赢家永不放弃，放弃者永不获胜”这样的话。
John, tell me about your family's love affair with the famous football coach of the Green Bay Packers, Vince Lombardi. That's right. So when you watch the Super Bowl, at the end, they give a trophy. And the trophy is called the Lombardi trophy, Vince Lombardi. And he is nothing short of a god around Wisconsin. He was the football coach. And he said things like winners never quit and quitters never win.
他跟我们家说话的语气就好像他是我们自己人一样。他对着我所处的这个世界的蓝领阶层说话，就像他是一个神一样。现在，包装工队赢得了前两届超级碗。当然，文斯·隆巴迪现在已经被推崇到了传奇的境界，可以说是这样。但正如你在你家里所说的那样，他不仅仅是一个橄榄球教练。他的理念、他的思想，这些定义了你家人对什么是对、什么是错的看法。
And he spoke to my family as if he was one of us. He spoke to the blue collar types of my world as if he was a God. Now the Packers won the first two super balls. And of course Vince Lombardi now has been elevated to the realm of legend, I would say. But as you say in your family, he was more than just a football coach. He was his ideas, his thinking, these defined the way your family thought about what was right and what was wrong.
哦，确实如此。我的意思是，文斯·隆巴迪的话，它们就是一种生活方式。它们是引导人们过上更好生活的信条。我听说作为一个青少年，这种精神的一部分融入了你体内，你在很小的时候就对高尔夫这项运动产生了热爱，不一定是因为我家人打高尔夫，而是因为我们有邻居打高尔夫。然后我可以和我的邻居一起去高尔夫球场。我爱上了高尔夫。我八岁时参加了我的第一场高尔夫锦标赛。最后我赢得了那场比赛。所以在很小的时候，高尔夫球打得挺不错的。我从来没有接受过任何形式的正式课程。我们没有钱上课。高尔夫是我充满激情且我打得还不错的领域。
Oh, that's right. I mean, Vince Lombardi's words, they were a way of life. And they were words to follow to lead a better life. I understand that it's a teenager, some of the spirit fed into you, a love for the sport of golf at a very young age, not necessarily because my family played golf, but because we had neighbors who played golf. And then I could go with my neighbors to the golf course. And I fell in love with golf. I played in my first golf tournament when I was eight years old. And I ended up winning the tournament. So I was pretty good at golf at a young age. I never received any formal lessons of any sort at all. We didn't have money for lessons. And golf was a passion that I was pretty good at.
我在高中时意识到，高尔夫可以成为我真正能够上大学的途径。最后我被威斯康星大学史蒂芬斯角分校招募了，他们给了我一份高尔夫部分奖学金。我想这真的是我上大学的唯一原因。这一定是一段意气风发的时期。
And I realized through high school that golf could be my avenue to actually be able to go to college. And I ended up getting recruited by the University of Wisconsin at Stevens Point, and they gave me a partial golf scholarship. And I think that's really the only reason why I went to college. This must have been a heady time.
你当时真的考虑过走职业道路的可能性吗？这一定是一段意气风发的时期。你当时真的考虑过走职业道路的可能性吗？是的，绝对考虑过。我作为一名成绩斐然的高尔夫球手进入大学。在我的高中时代和一些比赛中，我曾与美国各地的一些顶尖竞争对手交过手。
Did you actually consider the possibility of going pro? this must have been a heady time. Did you actually consider the possibility of going pro? Yeah, absolutely. I was coming in to the university as a very accomplished golfer. I had played against some of the best competition around America throughout my high school days and in some tournaments.
而且我抱有很高的期望，认为自己最终能成为一名职业高尔夫球手。嗯，有一次周末你从大学回家，在当地一家俱乐部打了一天高尔夫。我听说你遇到了几个你在高中时经常同场竞技的高尔夫球手。是的，完全没错。所以在我大一的那个秋天第一个学期，我们有一个周末没有高尔夫比赛，我就回家了。那是星期五，我去了麦迪逊的一家乡村俱乐部，叫切罗基乡村俱乐部（Cherokee Country Club）。我和几个朋友去了那里，碰巧的是，史蒂夫·斯特里克（Steve Stricker）等人也在那里，切罗基人也在那里，还有其他非常优秀的大学高尔夫球手。我注意到了一件事，我注意到，他们击球比我远得多。他们随心所欲地打出右曲球、左曲球。他们能打出低弹道、高弹道。他们正在做所有我一直梦想着能够稳定做到的事情。但我在心里对自己说，看，他们正在做所有我一直梦想着能够稳定做到的事情。
And I had very high aspirations that I could eventually become a professional golfer. Now, you came home from college one weekend and spent a day playing golf at a local club. I understand you ran into a couple of golfers you used to compete against in high school. Yeah, that's exactly right. So that first fall, of my freshman year at Stevens Point, we had a weekend off of golf, and I ended up coming home. So it was a Friday and I went out to a country club in Madison called Cherokee Country Club. And I went out there with a few friends, and as it happens, there were people like Steve
但我转念一想，看，这只是热身，而且我在果岭周围总能把杆数追回来，因为我的推杆真的很好，短切球技术也很棒。所以，让我们看看会发生什么，因为每个人都在星期六开车出发了。所以这挺有意思的，因为我在一号发球台开球时心里在想。你知道的，同样的球场，同样的天气条件，我和他们对抗。让我们看看一轮结束交分卡时会发生什么。结果怎么样？好吧，我要带来更多坏消息了，因为这些家伙打出了67、68、68、69的成绩，大概是低于标准杆5杆、4杆之类的。我其实打得不算太差，最后打出了75杆，大概高于标准杆3杆。
Stricker there, Cherokeelli was there, and other very good college golfers. And I noticed something, I noticed, they were hitting the ball a lot further than me. They were shaping the ball from right to left and left to right at their wish. They were hitting low balls, high balls. They were doing everything that I've kind of dreamed of being able to do consistently. But I thought to myself, look, they were doing everything that I've kind of dreamed of being able to do consistently.
这些家伙比我少用了六、七、八杆。我在想，哇，这些家伙比我记忆中厉害多了，而且跟这些人相比，我也没有自己记忆中那么好。对于我们观众中不懂高尔夫的人来说，杆数的这种差距意味着什么，约翰？这是一种微不足道的差距吗？哦，我希望这只是微不足道的差距，我们所有人都熟悉学校的成绩。我想让你们把他们的成绩想象成A或者A加，
But I thought to myself, look, it's warm-ups and I always get strokes back around the green because I'm a really good potter and I have a really good shipping game. So, let's see what happens because everyone was going out on the car set day. So, this is kind of fun because I was thinking to myself as I teed off on the first tee. You know, same course, same weather conditions, me against them. And let's see what happens at the end of the round when we bring our scores in. And what happened? Well, I'll come some more bad news because these guys are coming in shooting 67 68 68, 69, which is like 500 power, 400 power, etc. And I didn't play that poorly and I ended up shooting 75, which is like three
而我想让你们把我的成绩想象成D减吧。哇，完全处于分布的两端。所以这一定对你打击很大。发生了什么？你有没有试图探究导致这个实力差距的根本原因。哦，当然。所以这确实让人感到困扰，但我说，看，这只是一轮比赛。
over par. These guys are beating me by six, seven, eight strokes. And I'm thinking, wow, these guys are a lot better than I remember them being, and I'm not as good compared to these guys is what I remembered. For the non-Golfers in our audience, what is that difference in Strokes mean, John? Is that something that's a trivial difference? Oh, I wish it was a trivial difference, so all of us are familiar with grades. I want you to think about their grade as an A or an A plus And I want you to think about my grade is probably a D minus. Wow The totally different ends of the distribution So that must have been very disturbing to you. What what happened? Did you try and get to the bottom of this This achievement gap. Oh, absolutely. So it was disturbing, but I said, look, it was one round.
我开始想，你知道，也许一轮比赛，没那么糟。所以那天晚上，实际上是那个周五晚上，我开始做研究。所以这是1987年的秋天。没有互联网。所以我不得不去当地的图书馆，翻阅当地的体育版面来寻找高尔夫比分。我花了一整晚。我花了第二天也就是周六。我说，我今天不去打高尔夫了，
And I started to think, you know, maybe one round, it's not so bad. So I started to do research that night, actually, that Friday night. So this is the fall of 1987. No internet. So I had to go to the local library and I had to page through local sports pages to look for golf scores. And I spent all that night. I spent the next day Saturday. I said, I'm not going to go out golfing.
我要做研究。我要收集数据。我周日一整个上午和下午都在做这件事。当我在那个周日晚上开车返回威斯康星大学史蒂芬斯角分校时，我整个人都崩溃了，因为我意识到他们把我远远甩在后面了。过去几年里，他们进步的速度太惊人了。而我却没有。过去几年里，他们进步的速度太惊人了。而我却没有。所以，这一切让我明白，如果我继续努力工作其实也没有什么意义，那个梦想已经结束了。但随之而来的是乐观，因为我意识到可能还有别的什么东西是我可以擅长的，我可以把注意力转移到另一种活动上。那这个别的什么东西是什么呢？
I'm going to do research. I'm going to gather data. I spent all morning and afternoon on Sunday. And as I was driving back to the University of Wisconsin at Stevens Point that Sunday night, I was devastated because I realized that they were killing me. The last few, they had improved at such a strong clip. And I hadn't. at such a strong clip, and I hadn't. So, this all came to me that it doesn't really matter if I keep working hard, that dream is done, but then what also came up was optimism, because I realized that there might be something
那个别的什么东西后来证明是经济学。我意识到我天生就具备经济学家的思维方式。我当时在学习机会成本、边际思考以及所有这些基础概念，而我身边的人都在理解这些概念以及如何运用它们时遇到了困难。但对我和周围人相比，我环顾四周，然后对自己说，哇，这正是我思考世界的方式。
else that I could be good at, and I can move my attention to a different kind of activity. What was this something else? That something else turned out to be economics. And I realized that I naturally think like an economist. I was learning about opportunity cost and thinking on the margin and all of these foundational concepts and everyone around me was having trouble understanding these concepts and understanding how to use them. But for me, I looked around and I said to myself, wow, this is just how I think about
这正是我运用批判性思维技能的自然方式。所以在遭受打击的同时，我正在了解一个让我深深着迷的新世界，并且我意识到我在这一领域还挺擅长的。现在，值得强调的是，约翰其实很擅长打高尔夫。比他同龄的大多数人都好得多。但他意识到，比90%的竞争对手更好，还不足以成为一名职业高尔夫球手。
the world. This is just my natural way of using critical thinking skills. So at the same time, I was being devastated. I was learning about a new world that I was really fascinated with, and I was realizing I was pretty good at it. Now, it's worth underlining that John was pretty good at golf. A lot better than most people his age. But he realized being better than 90% of the competition wasn't going to be good enough to be a professional golfer.
远不如转到一个能让他成为真正明星的领域。当时的选择实际上并非在高尔夫和经济学之间做抉择。选择是在“表现得很好”和“跻身最顶尖行列”之间二选一。经济学家对这个概念有一个专门术语。它被称为比较优势。公司和个人都应该专注于那些与他人相比具有比较优势的领域。随着约翰将他的梦想从PGA巡回赛转向教职休息室，他开始遇到来自经济学的其他理念，这些理念帮助他理解了为什么人们无法放弃本该放弃的事情。
Far better to move to a field where he could be a real star. The choice was not actually between golf and economics. The choice was between being very good and being among the best. Economists have a term for this idea. It's called competitive advantage. Both companies and people should focus on areas where they have a competitive advantage over others. As John reshaped his dreams from the PGA tour to the Faculty Lounge, he started to encounter other ideas from economics that helped him understand why people failed to quit things they ought to quit.
其中一个最重要的理念，就是对犯错的恐惧。当需要放弃某件事并开始新事物时，你会想：我会失去什么？从高尔夫转向经济学，我放弃了什么？这是我们所有人都在苦苦挣扎的问题，它被称为损失厌恶。所以损失厌恶是一个古老的心理学概念，我相信你们的听众都能理解，那就是损失带来的痛苦比同等收益带来的快乐更大。现在，这种偏好在市场中存在，在带有学生的实验室中存在，在首席执行官中也存在。现在，我们必须考虑到这一点，在首席执行官中也存在。现在，我们必须考虑到这一点，
One of the most important ideas, the fear of making a mistake. When it comes time to quit something and start something new, you're thinking, what am I going to lose? What am I giving up by moving from golf to economics? And that's something that we all grapple with and it's called loss of version. So loss of version was an old psychological concept that I'm sure your listeners understand that losses hurt more than comparable gains. Now, this kind of preference is found in markets, it's found in laboratories with students, it's found among CEOs. Now, here we have to think about, It's found amongst CEOs. Now, here we have to think about,
我希望尽自己最大努力去理解，当损失厌恶的倾向影响我的决策时该怎么办。因此，我在课堂上了解到人们存在损失厌恶，我在想，你知道吗，我真的很想把损失厌恶抛到一边，因为我不想让它干扰我做出最优决策。而我认为与我们这里讨论的内容密切相关的另一个概念是沉没成本的概念。你能结合这个决策的背景谈谈这一点吗？
I want to do my best to understand when loss ofverse tendencies are affecting my decision-making. So I'm learning in the classroom that people have loss ofversion, and I'm thinking, you know what, I really want to put loss ofversion on the sidelines because I don't want it to interrupt with my optimal decision-making. And the other concept that I think is closely related to what we're talking about here is the concept of sunk costs. Can you talk about that in the context of this decision?
当我想到沉没成本时，我希望每个人都把它们看作是你过去已经付出、永远无法收回的成本或投资。所以在高尔夫的例子中，我作为10岁、12岁、14岁和16岁的小孩所花费的所有时间，那些都已经花掉了，那些已经不复存在了。而且根本不可能把它们收回来。现在，尽你最大努力去忽视这些是很重要的。这是一个很高的要求，对吧？因为我要求你做的是忽视遗憾。
When I think about sunk costs, I want everyone to view this as these are costs or investments that you've made in the past that you can never recover. So in terms of the golf example, all of the hours that I spent as a 10 year old and a 12 year old and a 14 year old and a 16 year old, those have already been spent, those are gone. And it's impossible to recover those. Now, it's important that you do your best to ignore those. That's a hard ask, right? Because what I'm asking you to do is ignore regret.
因为很多时候，当我们过去不断地进行投资、投资、再投资时，如果我们不得不改变方向，我们就会感到后悔。我们会说：我想承认这些沉没成本，因为如果我继续前行并改变所有这些事情，我会感觉真的很糟糕。因此，当涉及转换活动或保持灵活性时，这是一个非常重要的概念，我们必须尽我们所能去忽视这些沉没成本。所以，让这些决定变得格外艰难的原因之一，而且也许在关于你第一次婚姻的那个例子中比在高尔夫的例子中更清晰，那就是在你准备把某件事搁置一旁的那一刻，下一步要做什么往往并不明确。你能谈谈这种观点吗：我们许多人觉得下一章充满了模糊性？如果你不知道下一章会是什么，如果我们没有像你那么幸运，知道下一章已经写好并且清晰地摆在眼前，那么这种模糊性就是巨大痛苦和不安的来源。是的，完全正确。
Because a lot of times when we invest, invest, invest in the past, if we have to change course, we have regret. And we say, I want to recognize those sunk costs because if I go ahead and change all of those things, I feel really bad. So it's a very important concept when it comes to moving activities or being mutable that we really have to ignore is best we can, these sunk costs. So, one of the things that makes these decisions especially hard, and perhaps this is clearer
所以我们不喜欢不确定性，我们不喜欢做出把我们引向未知世界那类选择。当我考虑进入未知的广阔天地时，当你想想我的婚姻时，你的看法完全正确，我从16岁起就一直爱着这个女人。而突然之间，现在我45、47岁了，却在想：什么是未知的广阔天地？
in the example where you told me about your first marriage, rather than the example of golf, which is that at the point at which you're setting one thing aside, it's often unclear what the next thing is going to be. Can you talk about this idea that many of us find the ambiguity of the next chapter? If you don't know what that next chapter is going to be, if we're not as fortunate as you in knowing that, you know, the next chapter is written and it's clear in its front of us, that that ambiguity is a source of of great unhappiness and discomfort. Yeah, that's correct.
接下来是什么？我毫无头绪，因为我甚至从未考虑过这个问题。但想到要走向未知的广阔天地，接下来是什么？我毫无头绪，因为我甚至从未考虑过这个问题。但想到要走向未知的广阔天地，想到要面对一个模糊的情境或不确定的情境，这真的很可怕。这在很多情况下导致我们死守现状，远比我们应该做的要多得多。经济学中还有另一个概念与我们讨论的关于放弃所面临挑战的话题相关，约翰。
So we don't like uncertainty and we don't like making choices that lead us to sort of the world of the unknown. And when I think about going into the great unknown, you're exactly right when you think about my marriage, I had been loving this woman since I was 16 years old. And all of a sudden, now I'm 45, 47 years old, saying, what is the great unknown?
你能用一个例子解释边际收益递减原则，并告诉我它与我们厌恶放弃事物的现象有什么关系吗？边际收益递减是经济学中的基础概念之一，即我们做某事的次数越多，某事物的每一个额外小时、每一次额外的购买或消费（比如一块糖果），都会带来边际收益递减。
What is next? And I have no idea because I've never even thought about it. But the thought of going to the great unknown, what is next? And I have no idea because I've never even thought about it. But the thought of going to the great unknown, the thought of going to an ambiguous situation or in uncertain situation, this is scary. And this causes us in many cases to stick with what we have a lot more than we should. There's another concept from economics that's relevant to our discussion about the challenges involved with quitting, John.
这意味着如果你一遍又一遍地做这件事，最终收益会变得不那么好。随着时间推移，这被称为边际收益递减规律。当我思考自己在慈善筹款领域所做的一些工作时，我也有幸遇到了这个规律。在约翰选择高尔夫还是经济学的案例中，他必须放弃一件事去做另一件事。
Can you explain the principle of diminishing returns with an example and tell me what it has to do with the phenomenon of our aversion to quitting things? Diminishing returns is one of these foundational concepts in economics that the more we do something, every extra hour of something or every extra purchase or consumption of a candy bar, for example, there are diminishing returns.
但边际收益递减规律提出了一个更微妙的心理挑战。在这种情况下，你并不是在放弃什么。你正在做的事情仍然有效，你也应该继续去做。只是不要像以前做得那么多罢了。约翰在与一家名为“微笑列车”（Smiletrain）的慈善组织合作时发现了这一点。而微笑列车正是一个伟大的组织，他们派遣医生出国前往发展中国家，试图修复这些孩子的唇腭裂。所以他们每个月向人们寄出大约一百万封邮件
And what that means is if you do it over and over again, eventually the returns become not very good. Through time it's called the law of diminishing returns. And I was kind of met with this law when I think about some of the work that I've done in the area of charitable fundraising. In the case of John's choice between golf and economics, he had to give up one thing to do another.
试图说服他们为这项事业捐款。我开始问他们，好吧，你们实际上多久寄一次这些邮件？因为我曾向微笑列车捐过款，然后他们开始每个月给我寄一封邮件。他们说，好吧，如果有热心捐赠者已经捐过款，并且我们认为他们希望继续捐款，我们希望给他们很多捐款的机会。于是我们开始对此进行研究，我们探讨了，你是应该每个月寄出一封信，还是应该每个季度、每六个月或一年一次？我们本质上发现的是，他们绝对处于边际收益递减的区间，因为如果你每个月都寄，大多数筹款人的实际效果，其实比他们一年只寄一两次还要差。哇。换句话说，你几乎在，你在惹恼那些捐赠者，他们会说，你为什么用这么多、这么多的推销来烦我？ exatamente。你真的把捐赠者吓跑了，也许你当时，
But the law of diminishing returns presents a psychological challenge that is subtler. In this case, you are not giving up something. The thing you are doing still works, and you should continue to do it. Just not as much as you were doing before. John discovered this in his work with a charitable organization called Smiletrain. And Smiletrain is just a great organization that sends doctors overseas to the developing world to try to fix cleft palettes of these kids. So they send out, you know, roughly a million mailers every month to people
你的表现显得太绝望了，或者你太频繁地塞满他们的收件箱。他们说，听着，我受够了。我要把钱捐给别人。这真的是边际收益递减的一个例子。真的，这说明他们应该把频率降低到一年也许一两次吗？所以我们已经探讨了导致我们不愿放弃事物的许多不同因素，沉没成本和边际收益递减的问题。
to try to convince them to give to the cause. And I started to ask them, well, how often do you actually send these mailers? Because I had given to smile train and they started sending me a mailer every month. And they said, well, if there's a hot donor who has given and we think they want to keep giving, we want to give them a lot of chances to give. So we started doing research on this and we explored, you know, should you send out a letter every month or should it be every
但我认为我们的整个文化中也存在着某种深入骨髓的东西，基本上推动了这一点。我们听了太多关于坚持和毅力的美德，尤其是在体育和商业领域，我们热爱谈论那些永不放弃的人。但也许我们没有使用文斯·隆巴迪的原话，但我们的行为举止就好像我们用了那样。你知道的，“赢家永不放弃，
quarter or every six months or once a year? And what we essentially found was they for sure were in the region of diminishing returns because if you send it every month, most of our fundraisers were actually doing worse than if they only sent once or twice a year. Wow. In other words, you were almost, you were upsetting the donors who were saying, why are you bothering me with so many, so many pitches? Exactly. You were really turning donors off and maybe you were,
放弃者永不获胜”，对吧？当我思考放弃的问题和最优放弃决策时，它确实包含两个部分：一部分是私人的，也就是你个人层面不去这么做，你有沉没成本，还有损失厌恶怎么办，以及模糊性怎么办，这些都是
you were acting too desperate or, or you were filling their inbox too often. And they said, look, I'm done. I'm going to give to somebody else. And that's really an example of diminishing returns. And really, what does this say that they should quit at maybe one or two a year? So we've looked at a number of different factors that drive our reluctance to quit things, the problem with San Cos and diminishing returns.
个人层面上的问题。我们必须在个人层面上努力去改善这些以做出更好的决策。但方程的另一部分非常非常强大。那就是社会到底告诉我们该做什么，社会告诉我们不该做什么。当你想到放弃时，至少在美国以及我长大的地方，我被教导：如果你放弃了，你就是个失败者。听着，不仅仅是我或我的家人。你可以在谷歌上输入“励志名言”和“放弃”，把它们搜出来。你会发现，有足够多的海报能够用这些不同类型的励志名言填满世界上每一座博物馆。这告诉我，社会对放弃已经表明了立场。而那个立场就是：放弃是你用自己的选择所能做的事情中最令人反感的事情之一。你知道，当然，那些海报并没有谈论那些本不该放弃却没放弃的人。所以，是的，迈克尔·乔丹在1997年NBA总决赛中带病坚持比赛并且赢了，但你知道，许多忽视身体信号的人发现他们的身体最终垮掉了。这几乎就像是围绕着那个未被承认的成本存在着一个沉默的阴谋。
But there's also I think something in our culture, writ large, that basically drives this. We hear so much about the virtues of persistence and perseverance, and especially in sports and business, we love to talk about the people who never give up. But maybe we don't use Vince Lombardi's words, but we sort of act as if we do. You know, winners never quit,
这是一个很好的观点，因为当你观看奥运会，或者当你观看足球世界杯，观看体育赛事或任何类型的赛事时，总会有那种让人感觉良好的故事。那种关于，你知道吗，这是一个42岁的人，自18岁起就一直试图参加奥运会，最终在42岁时圆梦的故事。然后他们请来了他们的幼儿园老师，请来了奶奶，他们都说，你看，小约翰，他从未放弃。
quitters never win, right? When I think about the quitting problem and the optimal quitting decision, it really is one part private, and that's the individual that you don't do, you have some cost, what about loss of version, what about ambiguity, and that's
看看他现在。他进了奥运会。听着，那些都是很棒、能让人感觉良好的故事。我喜欢这些故事。但是，那成百上千万人呢？他们浪费了自己的精湛技能和机遇，他们不断尝试、不断尝试、不断在一个干涸的洞里向下挖掘，投资于一个永远不会成功的事情，因为他们被告知：你绝不能放弃。
on the individual. And we individually have to work on that to make better decisions. But the other part of the equation is very, very powerful. And that's exactly what does society tell us to do and what does society tell us not to do. And when you think about quitting, society at least around America and where I was raised, I was taught, if you quit, you're a loser. And look, it's not just me or my family. You can type in inspirational quotes and quitting, type that into Google. And what you'll find is there are more posters that could fill every museum in the world with these different types of inspirational quotes. Now that tells me that society has taken a stance on quitting. And that stance is, it's one of the most repugnant things you can do
归根结底在于个人。我们需要各自努力来做出更好的决策。但方程式的另一部分非常非常强大，那就是社会告诉我们该做什么，不该做什么。当你考虑放弃时，社会——至少在美国以及我长大的地方——教导我的是，如果你放弃了，你就是个失败者。听着，这不仅仅是我或我的家人。你可以在谷歌上搜索关于放弃的励志名言。你会发现，有足够多的海报来填满世界上每一家博物馆，上面写着各种不同类型的励志名言。这告诉我，社会对放弃已经表明了立场。而那个立场就是，放弃是你所能做的最令人厌恶的事情之一
with your choices is to quit. You know, and of course the posters are not talking about the people who didn't give up, but should have given up. So, you know, yes, Michael Jordan played through illness in the 1997 NBA final and he won, but you know, lots of people who ignore what their bodies tell them find that their bodies fall apart on them. It's almost like there's a conspiracy of silence around that unacknowledged cost.
你的选择就是放弃。你知道，当然，那些海报并没有谈论那些没有放弃但本该放弃的人。所以，是的，迈克尔·乔丹在1997年NBA总决赛中带病坚持比赛并赢得了胜利，但你知道，许多忽视身体信号的人发现他们的身体垮了。这几乎就像是围绕着那个未被承认的代价存在着一种沉默的阴谋。
That's a great point because when you watch the Olympics or when you watch the World Cup in soccer or watch a sporting event or any kind of event, there is always that feel good story. That story about, you know what, this is a 42-year-old who has been trying since their 18 to make the Olympics, and they finally made it when they're 42. And then they bring on their kindergarten teacher, they bring on grandma, and they all say, you know, little Johnny, he never gave up.
这真是个绝佳的观点，因为当你观看奥运会、世界杯足球赛、体育赛事或任何类型的活动时，总会有那种让人感觉良好的故事。那个故事是关于，你懂的，这是一个42岁的人，从18岁起就一直试图参加奥运会，最终在42岁时做到了。然后他们请来了他的幼儿园老师，请来了奶奶，他们都说，你看，小约翰尼，他从来没有放弃过。
And look at him now. He's in the Olympics. And look, those are great, feel good stories. And I love those stories. But what about the hundreds of millions of people who have wasted their great skills and their opportunities who try and try and try and they keep digging down a dry hole and investing in something that will never work because they were told you shun quit.
看看现在的他。他进入奥运会了。听着，那些都是很棒、很温馨的故事。我也喜欢这些故事。但是，数以亿计的人浪费了他们出色的技能和机会，他们不断地尝试、尝试、再尝试，却一直在枯井里死磕，投资于一个永远不会成功的事情，仅仅因为他们被告知要摒弃放弃，又该作何感想呢？
Where's their story? When we come back, how to battle our psychological limitations with our psychological strengths? You're listening to Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. Think of all the things in your life you should have quit years before you actually did. Now, think about things you should quit that are in your life today. Economist John List has spent time asking this question. Why don't you stop doing those things? John, you recently surveyed people who changed their jobs. What reasons did they give you for the change?
他们的故事在哪里？节目回来后，我们将探讨如何用心理优势来战胜心理局限。欢迎收听《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。这是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。想想你生活中那些本该在几年前就放弃、却一直拖到今天才放弃的事情。现在，想想你今天生活中应该放弃的事情。经济学家约翰·利斯特花了很多时间来探讨这个问题。为什么你没有停止做这些事情？约翰，你最近调查了那些换工作的人。他们给出了什么离职理由？
I asked a simple question. Why did you quit? And reason number one was I lost the meaning of work. That's a good reason. Reason number two, I didn't get the promotion that I thought I deserved. I'm gonna make sense. Reason number three, I didn't get the pay raise, I thought I deserved.
我问了一个简单的问题：你为什么离职？排在第一位的理由是：我失去了工作的意义。这是一个好理由。排在第二位的理由是：我没有得到我自认为应得的晋升。这说得通。排在第三位的理由是：我没有得到我自认为应得的加薪。
Reason number four, I didn't get along with coworkers as well as I used to get the pay raise. I thought I deserved. Reason number four, I didn't get along with coworkers as well as I used to get along with them. You know, all the way down to reason number 10, I didn't like my cubicle. That's it. That's it. Now importantly, not one person said, you know what, my opportunities got better.
排在第四位的理由是：我和同事的关系不如以前好了。我自认为应得的加薪……我刚刚说到排在第四位的理由，我和同事的关系不如以前好了。你知道，一直到排在第十位的理由：我不喜欢我的格子间。就这些。就这样。重要的是，没有一个人说，你知道吗，我的机会变得更好了。
And because my opportunities got better, I decided to leave my old job. So when people were making a list or telling you the reasons they quit, what you're saying is they came up with reasons they didn't like that current job, as opposed to saying there was another job that was even better than the one I have right now.
而且因为我的机会变得更好，我决定离开旧工作。所以当人们列出清单或告诉你他们离职的原因时，你的意思是他们列举的是他们不喜欢目前工作的原因，而不是说有另一份工作比我现在的好。
That's exactly right. In each case, it was a push factor. And that's a fundamental mistake because you should be just as likely, if not more likely, to move from your job when your opportunity set gets better. So economists have talked for a long time about opportunity cost. Could you just define the term for me, John? It's when you decide to do something. What is the next best alternative that you would be doing with your time?
完全正确。在每种情况下，这都是一种推动因素。这是一个根本性的错误，因为当你的机会集变好时，你应该同样甚至更有可能离开你的工作。因此，经济学家长期以来一直在谈论机会成本。约翰，你能为我定义一下这个术语吗？这是当你决定做某事时。你用你的时间去做的下一个最佳替代方案是什么？
And that next best alternative represents the opportunity cost of your time. Now we can also think about that in terms of dollars. If I go to Starbucks and buy a latte for $4, I'm doing that because I like to consume the latte. But the opportunity cost is what is the next best alternative that I would spend my $4 and buy? That's just not how people think through problems. And if we can train ourselves to be better critical thinkers and understand what are you giving up when you make that choice,
而那个下一个最佳选择代表了你时间的的机会成本。现在我们也可以从金钱的角度来考虑这一点。如果我去星巴克花4美元买了一杯拿铁，我这么做是因为我喜欢喝拿铁。但机会成本是我把这4美元花在买什么别的下一个最佳选择上。这根本不是人们思考问题的方式。如果我们能训练自己成为更好的批判性思维者，并理解你在做那个选择时放弃了什么，
you will make much better choices, not only in your own private life, but also at work and also in your community. You know, I'm thinking about that little known story back in the 1990s, a young guy was working at a company called DE Shaw, and they asked him to work on internet stuff, and he found that the business that he was building was growing astronomically, and you know, most people would have said, okay, you know, this is my ticket to start him at this company. I have the inside track to run the place in a few years,
你就会做出更好的选择，不仅在你的个人生活中，在工作中以及在你的社区中也是如此。你知道，我在想上世纪90年代那个鲜为人知的故事，一个年轻人曾在一家名为DE肖恩的公司工作，他们让他负责互联网相关的工作，他发现他正在建立的业务正在呈几何级数增长，你知道，大多数人会说，好吧，你知道，这是我在公司成名的通行证。几年内我将稳操胜券来管理这家公司，
but this kid didn't do that. He quit his high paying job and launched a little startup selling books online, and it wasn't that working at a high-flying job for D.E. Shaw was bad, but the opportunity costs of not founding Amazon were too high for Jeff Bezos. Yeah, that's a great story. That Bezos decides, look, I could kill it here at Shaw.
但这小子没有这样做。他辞去了高薪工作，创办了一家在网上卖书的小初创公司。在D.E.肖恩公司从事一份蒸蒸日上的工作并不是坏事，但对于杰夫·贝佐斯来说，不创立亚马逊的机会成本太高了。是的，这是一个很棒的故事。贝佐斯决定，听着，我可以在肖恩这里大干一场。
But if I continue to work at Shaw, I will have to forego starting up a bookshop and that bookshop ends up taking over the world. I mean, some ways, John, one thing I'm taking away from a lot of this conversation is the importance of paying attention to the future more than paying attention to the past. When I'm thinking about the things that I could be doing with my time, you know, when I think about, let's say I start eight projects, killing seven of those projects is painful
但如果我继续在肖恩工作，我将不得不放弃创办一家书店，而那家书店最终接管了世界。我的意思是，在某些方面，约翰，从这次谈话中学到的一点是，重视未来比重视过去更重要。当我在思考我可以利用我的时间做的事情时，你知道，当我想到，比方说我开始了八个项目，杀死其中七个项目是很痛苦的
because I have to think about all the time and effort that I put into those projects in the past. I might have sentimental or emotional attachments to those projects. And so getting rid of those projects is difficult. What I can't see, of course, is what freeing up my time, not working on those seven projects is going to get me in the future. And in some ways, I think what I'm hearing you say
因为我必须考虑到我过去在这些项目上投入的所有时间和精力。我对这些项目可能有着感性的或情感上的依恋。因此，摆脱这些项目是很困难的。当然，我看不见的是，腾出我的时间，不去做那七个项目，将来会给我带来什么。在某些方面，我想我听到你说的是
is to have more of a future orientation than a past orientation. No, I think that's exactly right. And when you think about great inventors like Thomas Edison, so he has a famous quote that says, I haven't failed 10,000 times. I have successfully found 10,000 ways that will not work. To me, Edison is a poster child child for the power of giving up. He's discarded these low voltage ideas in an effort to exactly as you're saying what will happen next, what will happen around the corner, what will happen tomorrow. It's the forward looking and what's
要更多地面向未来，而不是面向过去。不，我认为完全正确。当你想到像托马斯·爱迪生这样的伟大发明家时，他有一句名言：我没有失败一万次。我成功地找到了有一万种行不通的方法。对我来说，爱迪生是放弃力量的典型代表。他抛弃了这些低电压的想法，正是如你所说，为了接下来会发生什么，转角会发生什么，明天会发生什么。这是向前看的，以及
going to happen next and what am I giving up next by making that choice? So, John, you've made a powerful case in this conversation that we don't quit early or often enough, that there are many, many domains in our lives where we stick at things longer than we should or we enter domains and stay in domains that we shouldn't be in in the first place. But are the times when we shouldn't quit, times when pushing forward and persevering is actually the right choice? No, absolutely. And I think it depends on when you quit or when you pivot, what will you be doing in that new activity?
接下来会发生什么，以及我做出这个选择接下来要放弃什么？所以，约翰，你在这次谈话中提出了一个有力的观点，即我们放弃得不够早，也不够频繁，在我们生活中的许多领域，我们坚持的时间比应该的要长，或者我们进入了不该进入的领域并在其中停留。但是，有没有我们不应该放弃的时候，什么时候向前推进和坚持才是正确的选择？不，绝对有。我认为这取决于你什么时候放弃或什么时候转型，你在那个新活动中会做什么？
If you don't have a competitive advantage at it or it doesn't have a market if you're a firm, then I don't want you quitting to do something that you're not good at, or that's kind of useless. So you should always consider, when I quit, what am I going to do and understand that there's uncertainty and understand that, you know, it's the great unknown, but make sure that you're going to something that is real. Make sure it's your competitive advantage. Make sure you're going to enjoy it. And then you should go ahead and do it.
如果你在其中没有竞争优势，或者如果是一家公司，它没有市场，那么我不想让你放弃去做你不擅长的事情，或者那是毫无用处的事情。所以你总是应该考虑，当我放弃时，我要做什么，并明白存在不确定性，明白，你知道，这是未知的领域，但要确保你要去追求真实的事情。确保它是你的竞争优势。确保你会喜欢它。然后你应该继续去做。
If that quitting leads you to do something that is much more prosperous or it's much more satisfying for you than the activity that you're leaving. So you're not saying that we should quit casually or thoughtlessly. You once carried out a study that suggests that if you are agonizing over whether to quit something, flipping a coin can tell us something important. Tell us about that experiment, Dejon. Back in 2013, Steve Levit and I asked participants who were on the fence about some decision in their life to flip a virtual coin.
如果这种放弃让你做的事情比你正在离开的活动更加繁荣或更令人满意。所以你并不是说我们应该随意或轻率地放弃。你曾经做过一项研究，表明如果你在是否放弃某事上痛苦挣扎，抛硬币可以告诉我们一些重要的事情。给我们讲讲那个实验吧，约翰。早在2013年，史蒂夫·莱维特和我要求那些在生活中某个决定上举棋不定的参与者抛一个虚拟硬币。
So these were people who were thinking about quitting their jobs, they were considering selling their house, some were even considering leaving a romantic relationship. So what we told them is, look, if you flip a heads on the coin, you're gonna get a message that tells you to make the change. So you should quit the job or sell the house or leave the relationship.
所以这些人正在考虑辞职，他们正在考虑卖掉房子，有些人甚至考虑结束一段恋爱关系。所以我们告诉他们的是，听着，如果你抛出硬币正面，你会收到一条告诉你做出改变的信息。所以你应该辞职、卖掉房子或结束这段关系。
If you flip a tails, we advise them to keep the status quo. So now over the course of a year, we had over 20,000 people flip coins. Wow. And then we told them what to do. And to see how those decisions panned out, we emailed twice with each person two months after they toss a coin, and then six months later.
如果你抛出背面，我们建议他们保持现状。所以在一年多的时间里，我们有两万多人抛了硬币。哇。然后我们告诉他们该怎么做。为了解这些决定的结果，我们在他们抛硬币两个月后以及六个月后给每个人发了两次电子邮件。
Now, here's what happens. Those who made the major change, like filing for a divorce or leaving their job or buying a new house, they were more likely to report being happier two months later, and even happier still, six months later, compared to those who flipped a coin of tails and ended up keeping the status quo. What is this telling you, John?
现在，发生的情况是这样的。那些做出重大改变的人，比如申请离婚、辞职或买新房子，他们在两个月后更有可能报告自己更快乐了，而在六个月后甚至更快乐，相比之下，那些抛硬币得到背面并最终保持现状的人。这说明了什么，约翰？
This is telling me that on the one hand, we are not using economic thinking to make a decision to either pivot or quit. We are thinking in a very narrow way. And secondly, it tells me that when we're really on the margin and we're just grueling and grueling over what to do, it's likely you should make a change, taking account of all the biases that humans have. Opportunity cost neglect, opportunity cost neglect, sunk cost bias, loss of version, ambiguity of version, society telling you you shone
这说明一方面，我们在做转型或放弃的决定时没有使用经济思维。我们的思维方式非常狭隘。其次，它告诉我，当我们真正处于边缘状态，对要做什么感到非常煎熬时，你很可能会做出改变，同时考虑到人类的所有偏见。机会成本忽视，机会成本忽视，沉没成本偏误，损失厌恶，模糊厌恶，社会告诉你，你不应该
quit. Every one of these is telling you don't quit. So my advice is if you've been on the margin for so long, even with all of these entities, social and private, telling you don't quit, it's probably better if you just quit. John List is an economist at the University of Chicago. He's the author of the Vulterd effect, how to make good ideas great and great ideas scale. John, thank you for joining me today on Hidden Brain. Hey, thanks so much for having me, Shankar. If you have questions or thoughts about our conversation with John List and are willing to have those questions shared with a larger hidden brain audience, please record a voice memo on your phone and email it to us at ideasathydnbrain.org.
放弃。这里的一切都在告诉你不要放弃。所以我的建议是，如果你在边缘徘徊了这么久，即使有所有这些实体，社会和个人的，告诉你不要放弃，如果你直接放弃，可能会更好。约翰·利斯特是芝加哥大学的经济学家。他是《惊人的效应：如何将好创意变成伟大的创意并实现规模化》一书的作者。约翰，谢谢你今天做客《隐藏的大脑》。嘿，非常感谢邀请我，尚卡尔。如果你对我们与约翰·利斯特的对话有疑问或想法，并且愿意与更广泛的《隐藏的大脑》听众分享这些问题，请在手机上录制语音备忘录并通过电子邮件发送给我们：ideas@hiddenbrain.org。
60 seconds is plenty. Please remember to include your name and a phone number where we can reach you. Again, email the question to us at ideas at hiddenbrain.org and use the subject line quitting. Hidden Brain is produced by Hidden Brain Media. Our audio production team includes Bridget McCarthy, Annie Murphy-Paul, Kristen Wong, Laura Quarelle, Ryan Katz, Autumn Barnes and Andrew Chadwick. Tara Boyle is our executive producer. I'm Hidden Brain's executive editor. For today's Anson Hero, we bring you a story from our sister's show, My Anson Hero.
60秒就足够了。请记得附上您的名字和一个可以联系到您的电话号码。再次强调，请将问题通过电子邮件发送给我们：ideas@hiddenbrain.org，主题行写上“quitting”（放弃）。《隐藏的大脑》由隐藏的大脑传媒制作。我们的音频制作团队包括布里奇特·麦卡锡、安妮·墨菲·保罗、克里斯滕·王、劳拉·夸雷勒、瑞安·卡茨、奥特姆·巴恩斯和安德鲁·查德威克。塔拉·博伊尔是我们的执行制片人。我是《隐藏的大脑》执行主编。今天的“无名英雄”，我们为您带来姐妹节目《我的无名英雄》中的一个故事。
The story comes from psychologist Bob Chaldeini. When Bob was a senior in high school, he was really good at baseball. Good enough that one day, a scout showed up at his last game of the year and handed him a piece of paper. It was a contract an offer to play in the minor leagues. I was a center-fielder and I wanted all my life I wanted to be Mickey Mantle or Willie Mays with the big center
这个故事来自心理学家鲍勃·查尔迪尼。当鲍勃读高中高年级时，他棒球打得非常好。好到有一天，球探出现在他一年中的最后一场比赛中，递给他一张纸。那是一份合同，一份在小联盟打球的报价。我是一名中外野手，我一生都想成为米奇·曼特尔或威利·梅斯那样的超级中外野手
fielders at the time, and his pen wouldn't work. So he said, well, I've got another one in the car. So we walked to the car and along the way he said to me, so tell me something, are you any good at school? I said, yes, I am. You said good enough to get into college. Yes, I am. Good enough to finish college? Yes. Do you like it?
当场的外野手，而他的笔写不出字来。所以他说，好吧，我在车里还有一支。所以我们走向汽车，一路上他对我说，那么告诉我一件事，你学习好吗？我说，是的，我很好。你说能考上大学吗？是的，我能。能读完大学吗？是的。你喜欢它吗？
Do you like thinking about academic things? I love it. And he put the contract away. And he said, go to school kid. Because most likely you won't get to the majors. But what you've told me is that you're good at something you really like. That should be where you go. The truth is, he was right. I mean, I was pretty good, but I couldn't hit a slider, a good slider. And I was going to be seeing a lot more good sliders if I went into professional baseball. And he, I think, understood that, and gave me advice I've always been thankful for him
你喜欢思考学术问题吗？我喜欢。然后他把合同收起来了。他说，孩子，去上学吧。因为你很可能进不了大联盟。但你告诉我的事实是，你擅长你真正喜欢的事情。那应该是你去的地方。事实是，他是对的。我的意思是，我挺不错的，但我打不了滑球，那种高质量的滑球。如果我进入职业棒球界，我会看到更多高质量的滑球。我想他理解这一点，并给了我我一直感谢他的建议
for providing to me. Don't just go where your dream is. Go where your dream is that you're good at. Where you have the skills to realize the dream. He did something that was generous and I will always be indebted to him. Bob headed after college instead of the minor leagues. He went on to become an author and well-known psychology researcher at Arizona State University. His work was recently featured on Hidden Brain in two episodes about the science of influence, the title Persuasion
提供给我。不要只去追寻你的梦想。去追寻你擅长的梦想。去拥有实现梦想的技能。他做了一件慷慨的事，我将永远对心怀感激。鲍勃高中毕业后没有去小联盟，而是上了大学。他后来成为亚利桑那州立大学的作家和知名心理学研究员。他的作品最近在《隐藏的大脑》中亮相，有两集关于影响力科学的节目，标题为《说服（上）》和《说服（下）》。
Part One and Persuasion Part Two. We'd love to hear about your own unsung hero, use your phone to record your story and email it to us at myunsunghero at hiddenbrain.org. That's myunsunghero at hiddenbrain.org. All this month we're exploring different dimensions of what it means to be successful. We would love for you to listen to the entire series and share it with your friends. I'm Shankar Vedantam. See you soon. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们很想听听您自己的无名英雄的故事，用您的手机录下您的故事并通过电子邮件发送给我们：myunsunghero@hiddenbrain.org。邮箱是myunsunghero@hiddenbrain.org。整个月我们都在探索成功意味着的不同维度。我们希望您能收听整个系列并与您的朋友分享。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。再见。本集暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。